my guest tonight is an Emmy and Tony
award-winning actress she's also a
course a very talented singer whose
latest album is entitled for the girls
finally something for me please welcome
Kristin Chenoweth Kristin how are you
you look beautiful first of all I wore a
tie for you I've not been wearing a tie
but you know I adore you and I'm like
Kristen Chenoweth to me says real show
business and glamour so I put on a tie
for you to see I don't see I see from
here up so I don't see the hole oh yeah
yes yes what you want to change it okay
this is just like you're hosting an
awards show and you're and you're doing
outfit changes during on it no one's
done this yet no one's changed outfits
yet on a zoom interview this is a first
this is fantastic
it's very sensual to think of you
changing just off-camera I don't think
she can hear me of course you could hear
me and that was a creepy thing to say
wish I hadn't said it just you know just
the very idea of an attractive woman
stepping off camera and saying I'm
changing is you know something that
that's the imagination running wild oh
my god you look fantastic
you want to go to lunch I know there's a
lot of adjusting up here what's
happening with I didn't have time to do
the appropriate undergarments ladies and
gentlemen okay I'm gonna try and settle
down you're talking to a very repressed
Catholic boy who's been in quarantine
for seven weeks so just let's take it
easy you look beautiful I love what
you're wearing it looks fantastic
oh so much to talk about first of all
you know they always used to say about
James Brown hardest-working man in show
business I think you get that title he
has passed you are constantly on the go
constantly in front of crowds
how are you handling this tour as many
artists were I you know unlike now I'm
talking to my silverware by the way I
didn't even know I had a kitchen so you
did yes so I'm guessing your whole life
was you're on tour you're on the road
you're eating out you're eating
restaurant room service you're on the go
and then suddenly you're in a bus
station eating a sandwich out of a
vending
machine I hope you're getting paid by
the good people yes what's a nice list
me I salute the captain he like Captain
Crunch with crunch berries no I don't
want to waste my time and I don't need a
berry in my cereal whether it's a berry
or not it's not a berry I want to talk
to you you and I always chat about your
various relationships your search for
mr. right yes I've met some of your
candidates every now and then you enlist
me like the creepy older brother to like
come by and check the guy up tell us
there's a new boyfriend I hear tell
let's talk about that guy who is he well
he's really actually a I mean you're no
no it's ok it's ok get him young get him
young while her personalities still
forming you've been together for a year
and a half is that a guitarist
international wedding he was playing
instead of you busting my mojo it was my
father who kept coming up during the
wedding saying who's that who's that
who's that and I'm just like you need to
go away Jerry gentlemen so I can get my
mojo on with this guy this Josh Josh
yeah you have met him yet no but you
told me about it you said that you were
dating a guitarist and and I said what's
his name Josh and I immediately thought
okay that's my rival Josh that's why I
remember these things
immediately it was burned into my brain
that that
Josh must be destroyed josh is you've
been dating for a year and a half that's
good I did tell you you said that we
could come over so when we're done
socially distancing they want to come
over for dinner
that'd be great I want to have you over
oh you got enough time for another
another wardrobe change Kristin
Chenoweth this is I think a historic
moment multiple wardrobe changes during
her zoom interview and again very
attractive Kristin Chenoweth is now
undressing and then dressing just off
camera just over that way where I can't
see again probably creepy for a guy here
in quarantine in a room alone we'd be
talking about it changing she comes here
she comes let's clean it up people
here we go here she comes oh my god
that's a homework onesie why it's a
Christmas onesie could I get a mint of
Christmas movie this year their Hall of
Fame movie yes so they gave me the ones
I loved ones you looks fantastic it
looks good if you it's comfortable
additional elastic waistband I feel
guilty for eating the captain and I'm
comfortable you're you realize you're
regressing to childhood you're eating
children's food and you're dressed right
now as a child who needs to go to sleep
missile I think third grade I think
you're ready for third grade so the
onesie you're a fan of a onesie yes
especially I can get mine in the
chicken's apartment at Target because
think about it I'm 411 where am I going
to shop the kids defer so on tour before
this whole thing problems occurred which
we know what we're talking about here
yep I got a onesie at Target it was
winning the food and I actually would
have put it on now but it's in the dirty
clothes because I'm wearing it all the
time
yes
set your dog NBA basketball team or
Thunder yeah yes like thunder how are
you yeah this is what's happening to
late night I'm bringing my dog and we're
onesie and I'm bringing a captain and
crystal white yeah and again if you're
not getting paid by these companies you
should be getting paid by these I know
this was on my piano oh that's great I
like that is that your that's your
reading for the night yeah so one I am I
have to ask you ooh
you you got a lot of attention last time
you were on our show people were
commenting you harmonized to car alarms
yes and you did that on my program yes
loved it and it was pretty impressive
what are you doing lately you do
anything like that just around the house
- what yeah because I'm now noticing
everything huh everything I'm taking the
cell phone rings and I'm imitating I
can't stop myself
imitating cell phone rings think about
it okay so like my dad's it is it's a
Sergio Leone vibe that's what that is
right
yeah this is the one I used to warm up
does your dog freak out when you do that
yes yeah run into the other room I tell
her people paid money to hear me saying
she don't care you should say that paid
for your dog food I can train that dog
to be your comedy partner yes what are
you doing to stay in shape there was
work outs on line I was doing I'm doing
be heard yeah are you know I'm 75 years
old I'm not allowed to go on
I have two teenage kids that know all
about tik-tok but no I do not go on
tik-tok I always thought I'd be arrested
if I went on tik-tok more would go off
that exists there's a creepy man on tick
tock no I don't go - tick-tock well you
should and you should do some tape talks
with your kids because I'm doing them
and that's not the workout that's why
you know you just talk around you
imitate somebody I've been doing high
notes you know you know what I've been
doing I don't know why but before I hit
a high note let's go
seanny no seriously if you 1993 I'll be
there with sting and I'll go and he'll
give me a look like booth what's your
problem
[Music]
now you brought up ticked-off I want to
bring up something you've done this
thing that's been keeping you busy and
it's a cool idea maybe you could tell us
it's a musical video that you've been
working on yes I just released it um I
don't know if you've heard about I know
you have tiger King Joe lives that Zoo
is not very far from my parents house
okay
have I been because it seems like
something I would have wanted to do and
my dad said we would have never taken
you there it seems a little Shady
then it's Shady now you know and but
he's real popular of jail my dad anyway
yeah I'm obsessed and I'm obsessed with
Carol Baskin I'm positive she killed her
husband and fed into the Tigers I'm
positive of it or he's in the septic
tank but it doesn't matter
my friend injured lipless who wrote um
the song that I won the Tony for in
Charlie Brown wrote a Carol Bastion
parody it's called little pieces
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's another way that we're
alike is even in quarantine we'll find
things to do find things to do I bet you
you're crea graphic dances with your
your broom yes I mean I know you come in
I know it really you didn't the Beast
like the lamps in my room have come to
life I'm talking full-on to the mirror
I'm having arguments with myself at 3:00
in the morning Kristen this is good it's
what you're born to do it's yeah well
this too shall pass
we're all gonna come out the other side
of this I really look forward to seeing
you again in person
absolutely this makes my day to get to
talk to seriously I was like I'm going
crazy
you always cheer me up you are just a
such a talented burst of sunshine and
then when I like I get to go talk to
Kristen in the middle of this madness I
was very happy so that was okay that was
a heart yeah I have a malformed heart
good heart it wasn't that's a little
better when your first time you did it
it looked like I wish that your heart
were malformed and I one way kristin
chenoweth thank you so much for being a
pulse bye-bye take care of yourself and
I bow to you